okay first of all that was a very
interesting service I could identify
issues from both restaurants in a way
that I didn't expect from brilliance
panniers your phrase sumptuous delicious
finding that balance with the masalas is
a tough one love the way you had the
balls to make that premier the one issue
I had was the rawness of the vegetables
the peppers were barely cooked and it
didn't completely spoil the dish but it
didn't enhance it
Posada I thought the koftas were a bold
move
love the vegetables inside delicious the
gravy was seasoned beautifully they had
that right amount of heat the big shop
for me was the the overcooked rice I've
eaten in your restaurant I don't know
how well you cook and I didn't expect to
see overcooked rice today this
competition is not going to be won or
lost on one dish alone I'm looking for
the best restaurant in Britain brilliant
I turn up with a coach load of diners 30
of them jumping into the restaurant
eager to taste that food we got off to a
sluggish start but my god did those
diners enjoy that food I send in my
secret diners and again I've never seen
a restaurant so excited to help when
it's not even their fault good sign
Prasad I turn up in the back of beyond
of Bradford 30 diners could have barely
fit in the pressure was immense
however they loved the food then I sent
in my secret diner and he loved the food
this is a tough one a very tough one
sadly there's only one restaurant going
through to semi-final
the restaurant going through based on
everything I've seen and tasted
miss Prasad
okay walk
well done that restaurant will continue
being unique there's no two ways about
that and that was for me one of the
tightest and the closest decisions I've
ever had to make in our journey of 35
years we've won numerous awards and
would be would be back again like the
the SHA carries on and the brilliant was
carry on what
well tougher are your check yeah really
well done
and I'm so happy thank you for the
family and for the restaurant why
because the food is extraordinary oh
happy I can even think about it so happy
I'm so happy it was really difficult for
me because I wasn't in there every
single step of the way as a family
whenever we perform we're always
together service kitchen everything
together today I had to sit back and
look like I was enjoying food I didn't
have an appetite at all but you know
we're just I can't I can't tell you
fantastic
what an extraordinary day and I'm quite
sad to say goodbye to brilliant but
you've got to give it up for Prasad they
were amazing now the competition really
starts for them they're through the
semi-finals and they are gonna have to
really really pull stops out